[Music]
okay quick quiz i want you to guess what
this symbol is ready go
any guesses
come on time's running out
i'll give you a clue it's in the title
okay what you're looking at is the
federal aviation administration's
proposed symbol to identify verti ports
a place where electric vertical takeoff
and landing or ev toll aircraft could
take off and land see the faa is in the
process of drawing up some guidance over
how ev tiles could fit into urban areas
but where you might see this symbol in
the future could make or break some of
these ev toll companies and the
decisions being made could impact
everything from your future commute to
how clear the skies are around you so if
ev tolls take off
where are they going to land let's find
out
[Music]
okay first i want to show you why the
choice of landing sites could be more
important for these companies than how
fast they can fly come with me i'll
explain
[Music]
so currently when i head into work i
have a few options for how i get there
the quickest are taxi tube or express
train now they all travel at different
speeds stop at different frequencies and
take different routes but no matter
which mode i take it always takes me
around an hour to get into the office
and that's because of where the
departure sites are
the taxi may be slower than the express
train but it goes directly from door to
door the express train may move far
quicker and more directly but the
stations are miles from my home and
office and require additional travelling
at the start and end
this is super important for these ev
toll companies because if they're going
to dramatically cut travel times they're
going to have to be exactly where
customers need them to be or as the
companies themselves say having these
sites located where
people want to move to and from is is
very important to us these locations
have to be nearby where the nodes of
traffic exist so what options are they
exploring
well the first option is probably the
most obvious underutilized existing
airports see while america has some 5
000 airports a whopping 70 of air
traffic is handled by just 30 of them
joby and whisk were among two companies
that told me that they planned to
initially operate from airports as they
offered existing infrastructure designed
for aircraft and had air traffic control
what's more according to the faa some 95
of the us population lives within 30
miles of an airport i think that there's
the benefit to operating in airports
primarily as they're already accustomed
to operating aircraft that's great if
you're flying into town and need to get
to another airport but less so if you're
trying to get anywhere else within the
city so companies like archer and others
are also investing in developing landing
sites on inner city rooftops and if
you're thinking you've heard that before
you'd be right after all there are
already helipads on some buildings and
they could potentially be adapted to
land evital aircraft but existing
helipads present their own problems like
trying to figure out how charging
infrastructure or passenger terminals
could be integrated and that's what
we're working on right now so from an
access perspective we're working with
cities to understand you know the tempo
of operations the hours of operations to
ensure that we're integrating ourselves
and our operations into the city in a
manner that obviously provides as
minimal disruption as possible archery
is also exploring deploying landing
sites on the roofs of car parks they're
well located in cities the rooftops are
generally very underutilized and they're
generally built to handle large moving
loads the next option is to take things
a step further and build standalone
verti ports these custom-built evtel
stations would act as a hub where
aircraft could take off and land but
also park and charge the companies i
spoke to told me they'd likely be built
alongside existing transport hubs like
adding a bus station to a railway
terminus but they stressed that they'd
take longer to develop i think when we
talk about virtaports and all that
that's
that's a long lead time but one company
i spoke to had a very different idea of
where ev toll should be able to take off
and land from we
want to land at any flat surface that
can physically afford the vehicle so we
are really disbelievers in building
specialized voter ports that's sebastian
throne kitty hawk ceo and former leader
of google's self-driving car project and
according to him ev tolls should be able
to operate like ubers in the sky tap a
button and one comes to your door when
you put additional hubs in the middle
you lose some of the benefits because
now people have to change modalities
they might have to wait along the way
and so on that's not a sentiment that
many in the industry seem to share it's
hard to imagine a world in which you
know having these aircraft landing on
our neighborhood cul-de-sacs is
promoting a culture of safety wait wait
i just want to bring us back down to
earth for a moment because right now
none of these vehicles have carried
paying passengers and some of them may
never commercially take off but if they
do and this symbol becomes the new
landing pad where will we see it
well according to the faa's draft
guidance to begin with urban air
mobility will use existing helicopter
infrastructure but in the meantime these
companies are starting to snatch up roof
space in cities as they try and further
integrate into the urban environment so
keep your eyes open if you see this
symbol on the ground in the next few
years it could mean that ev toll
aircraft are finally taking off
hey where would verti ports make the
most sense for you let me know in the
comments below and if you're interested
in the future of how we get from a to b
then don't forget to subscribe see you
soon
[Music]